[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum but my voice sounds a
little bit sexier or a little bit
constipated
it's because i'm still jet lagged and
i'm still like oh my lord
that flight from australia has killed me
we're doing so
sometimes we do intros for two weeks
so we have you know this episode we had
done this intro for a lot from from we
did this intro last week how i'm boring
myself right now
is that even possible we have to yeah
people we're all jumping around the
world we're globetrotting yeah so we're
having to stockpile some stuff yeah also
sexy and constipated at the same time
yeah
is that possible
i mean if one man can do it let me let
me see if i can do it in the scene watch
hey
it's basically clint eastwood isn't it
how are you
well
i've had a long flight
i've taken my xanax and it's clogged me
up
guys thanks for listening to the podcast
today welcome hopefully uh you'll enjoy
today's podcast it's got a youngster on
today love this guy he's his his career
is booming and he's a friend of mine we
play hockey together and uh
it was good to have him in the studio he
was a real he was really fun he was he's
so full of life i remember what that was
like to be so full of life to have just
everything seemed so possible
where did that go
good lord sir
where'd it go i'm serious man uh before
we get into that big reminder everyone
tomorrow is the launch
of talkville that's right the smallville
rewatch podcast that tom welling and i
are doing if you loved smallville and
you want to have a little revisiting
where this all started make sure you
tune in wednesday july 13th to wherever
you get your podcasts and to get to see
more cool stuff we're doing head over to
talkvillepodcast.com
that's
t-a-l-k-v-i-l-l-e podcast
talkfieldpodcast.com
don't miss this folks
mark it down this is going to be an
adventure
ryan will be there i will be there talk
film podcast all right back to the
inside of you podcast now i just wanted
to promote that i've got a great episode
today um you know this this guy's career
is really blossoming that's all i could
say i'm excited that he's on the show i
think he was a really fun guest i think
you're gonna have fun with him he's
charming i love the stories about his
family his dad would just look his ass
i don't forget stuff like that and uh
the hockey stories that were you know he
sounds like he had a promising like he
could have made it as a as a hockey
player and uh
chose the dark side
acting
uh without further ado oh before we get
into that let me give you the handles if
you like the podcast today you want to
follow us at talkville podcast
i'm sorry
at inside of you podcast on instagram
and twitter at insideypod uh no at
inside of you podcast on
facebook facebook and instagram
citypod on the twitter
see i told you this you know it just
what can you do also if you want to join
patreon um
patreon if you don't know what it is
it's a place where people give back to
the podcast so it keeps us running keeps
us afloat so if you love the podcast and
you want to support it in any way go to
patreon.com insider p-a-t-r-e-o-n
dot com slash inside of you you can
become a patron i'll message you back
thanking you right after you do it
there's all different types of tiers you
could be the top tier which gets boxes
and
sign stuff from me every four months and
get your name shouted out on the podcast
at the end so it's uh it's a lot of fun
patreon.com inside of you
and without further ado i think oh by
the way the inside of you online store
has tons of great merch if you want
merch we've got so much new stuff inside
you glasses
uh mugs tumblers smallville stuff check
it out the inside of you online store
without further ado let's get inside of
gianni peolo it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
favorite horror movie you asked me huh
mm-hmm
you know i came in with the burning hot
questions burning hot i love how you the
first
question is for me
like that yeah it's it's fine i'm
actually taking over so you could you
could totally take over believe me i'd
like you to take over i wish ryan would
take over sometimes ryan take over dude
yeah what's your favorite horror movie
michael um
i'm gonna go with uh an easy one you
could say
i mean ma is a great scary movie i mean
it is it's not really a scary movie as
much as it is a thriller yeah but uh the
shining throwing up my credits
immediately what i
immediately goes mom ma is a good horror
movie i'm like all right take it easy
take it easy octavius
yeah
jeez man
here's the thing i know this is gonna be
very controversial to say
i watched the shining and i was not
impressed
maybe because there's so much behind a
young person it's just slow
it's supposed to be it's that slow burn
you're in this giant
castle-like hotel and yet you still feel
claustrophobic and
it's it's it's dated but it's still i
think it's so nostalgic to me that's why
it's so good but the exorcist is a great
one did that hold up for you it did a
little more than the shining i love how
i've lost your entire audience within no
way i was like i hate the shyness no no
no it's a different like how old are you
25 25 yeah you're 25 years old this
thing this movie came out uh
how was 40 years ago how old were you
when it came out um let's see i was
probably i was a little boy it came out
1980 yeah so i was eight years old you
were negative 25. yeah that's crazy
it's did you have you seen the shining
ryan
you haven't seen the shining wow we
gotta have screening at my house
well what's your favorite horror movie
i'm a scream fan just because i love
like i just love the comedy aspect and
because that's just you know who i am
too so i love i love scream
um
yeah i'd have to go with that scream
scream's a great horror movie but you
can tell it's generational yeah but i
think it crosses generations because i
think most i mean that was a huge movie
successfully yeah through every
demographic i think from like
15 to like 60 yeah people are loving
that freaking movie yeah you know what's
crazy is i'm looking at you and i'm like
this punk
i've known you we played hockey together
yeah and then you met like what five
years ago something like that and then
you're working for theo vaughn on his
podcast and the next thing i know you
have more followers than i have
[Music]
i mean you just like took off you got
this power book two ghost on stars that
just like
it's it's like one of the most popular
shows it just took off you have this
huge ratings and like
millions of followers
like i don't even know where to begin
with you so i was like you know he
hasn't been working that long you
haven't done that much stuff yeah i mean
you've been doing a lot lately
but i look at you and i'm like
how do you you're 25 years old and when
what was the first thing you that hit
the first
the first thing i ever booked was a hulu
show called chance it was my first guest
right right right and then i did a
couple guest stars guest stars um and
then ma was like kind of the big um one
that i that i booked but i actually
booked ma and then i booked uh my first
co-star on power like a week later so
and i was hanging out for a month before
i even won them so i had two jobs in the
can before i even went and shot any of
them
wow yeah and this happened when so this
was december of
2018. i book i book i booked my december
what the gardeners they come
they came at this i thought it was your
dog i thought it's your dog i was like
well that is my dog yeah but the
gardeners are outside but go ahead yeah
so so december 2018 i booked ma and i
booked power right back to back i went
and filmed my first co-star um
not my first co-star but my first day on
power because originally i booked it as
a co-star right um and then so you had
no idea that they're gonna keep you
around no so basically what happened is
i
i booked it as a co-star and i had two
scenes
and um it was just an [ __ ] like rich
white
cw character right so i it was like a
skeleton crew i worked as a local hire
so i lost like two thousand dollars i
flew myself in
uh to because they shoot that in new
york i obviously live here but my family
is from rhode island so i was like i'll
make a trip out of it yeah so i went
providence right yeah probably yeah
so i went to new york and we shot it um
and thank god the director because you
know the sides were i was trying to buy
pills from tariq my roommate at the
school choke but it was one scene and
i'm like hey let me let me buy pills and
it was just an [ __ ] wearing sperry's
this and that what are sperry's it's
like boat shoes it's like what every
rich [ __ ] from nantucket wears
are those those actually in fact yeah
these are
old spirits
but those are the sneakers these are
secrets
oh i know what you're talking about no
laces yeah it's right right it's
terrible right so i i'm gonna say i'm
wearing perry's but no the s just kind
of came off the bottom uh yeah no those
are cool those are sneakers yeah those
are all right i like those
yeah
so the director was like okay the next
two takes are yours because i knew what
i was there for like i'm not trying to
make it about myself this and that i go
there i do what i was supposed to do and
whatever so she's like next two takes
yours so i just improv like crazy i
totally changed the character i made him
funny i didn't make him an [ __ ] you
know white character this snap which
kind of is the way it was written and i
just changed it and then you know a
couple months later when the show came
out that's what made the cut and nothing
that was originally written made it
so
yeah it was really how do you learn
where did you learn to improvise i've
been i did on stage at ucb in
groundlings for years um i did i was
i performed pretty much at every indie
improv show in la for three years so
when she said the next two takes are
yours i was like got it i know what i
need to do but now are you improvising
with someone who knows what they're
doing as well um
my friend michael has been on the show
since he was 11 years old so he never
had to do any of that um so he he knows
how to improvise but like i i knew what
i was bringing to the scene it's not
about
you know a lot of people when they
improvise on like how do i give myself
more lines
and i know that that's the the downfall
that's the pit of death because then
they're like oh it's like how do you
make this scene and this character
better how do you make the show better
right so that's the way i approached it
ah so then i could sure way beyond your
years my friend yeah and i was 21 at
that point 22
um when i when i shot that so then
whatever a couple months go by i saw it
and then they called me and they said oh
we wrote you a whole story line for
season six so i was like oh dope so i
come back
and they're paying you more they're
flying you out there find me out there
all right all right good so they wrote
me a whole story line and i show up and
the first person i see is 50 cent at
breakfast and he comes up to me and he
goes um
uh we like keep doing what you're doing
we loved you you killed it and i was
like holy [ __ ] like
because he's yeah he's one of the
executive producers of the show he was a
main character on it for five seasons
four seasons um so it was just i was
like oh my god that's crazy and then the
show runner came up to me at the table
read um which i was so nervous for and
because my first table she came up to me
and she's like
keep doing what you're doing improv
whatever you want
add whatever in um i know you know what
you're doing and that kind of gave me
permission to just go because if the
showrunner was coming up with you and
say that
so it just became this whole thing you
do you improvise every episode you're in
every scene you're in no no no no not
every scene i'm in because some of the
more serious scenes are like exposures
yeah you don't need to do that you know
i'm not like that where i'm like i need
to do this maybe sometimes in a take
i'll like switch a couple words around
to make it feel a little fresh because
our writers are very collaborative like
that right um but if it's comedy like if
in which my character does have a lot of
that um i will
have four or five different jokes ready
to go to switch switch which each scene
and they eat it up eat it up love it
they don't tell you to back off they
just keep it coming never because i'll
always do it as scripted at least one
time and then they have it and then i
want to do you have a lot of lines for
the most part in in ghosts yeah yeah a
lot i mean season one it was um you know
the biggest workload i've ever had
season two it got you know a lot bigger
i was like wow and now season three it's
like working every day how do you uh
what's your work ethic i mean how long
does it take you to learn lines
in the beginning um
i i i run it like christ to run it like
crazy you know when you first get on a
show you're like i need to show up with
every single line i need to know this
like but and now you're like three
seasons in you're like okay let me do it
a couple of times and i'll play with it
when i get there right so i'll just
facetime a little brother at night and
he'll run it with me two or three times
so you still run lines with someone
you're you're you're yeah you run lines
every night with your brother yeah my
little brother how old is he he's 22.
and where does he live providence no uh
me and both my brothers live uh uh all
together here in l.a
you live with your brothers yeah well i
i should when i shoot new york i'm there
um so what kind of place you guys do you
have like this palatial you know yeah
it's nice i mean we're about to i'm
about to buy my house so that's going to
be a thing where it's going to be like a
you know a pad but right now it's just
like it's a condo that we all are in
right now and one of my best friends
lives with us too so it's us four and uh
we have literally the most fun like when
i get home from set i just sit on face
time with them for like an hour two
hours at night if i'm playing video
games sometimes we won't even talk for
like 20 minutes but i just like want to
feel like i'm there like when i get home
and i'm tired you know what's funny is i
always um i love face timing it's the
best you know and and
sometimes in fact when i meet a girl
online on a dating app i'll say let's
facetime immediately
i don't like facetime like i want to get
i want to see if i want to go out with
you yeah i don't know you yeah i don't
want to just take a chance of going out
with someone i don't know yeah and i
like facebook why are you face time am i
yes i face time with my grandma i face
time with my friends i face time with
anybody i love it i'm weird though i
find it weird if you facetime someone
you've never met i don't i don't think
so it's just like
it's like an action hey how are you oh
cool what do you do i make people feel
comfortable yeah and i like and then
afterwards i'll be like no i'm not going
to go out or i'm like hey she seems
really cool yeah i'm going to go out on
a date with her i mean it's one of the
greatest things steve jobs ever did
face time
i mean whoever thought we would be able
to facetime
it's pretty crazy it's pretty crazy but
you don't you don't think it's that cool
to do it like in the first meeting i
don't know i think it feels like a
consumer interview yeah it's like
interviewee and you don't really know
them so like me i could talk to anybody
me too so that's why i don't think it's
bad cause i'll make you feel comfortable
exactly but a lot of times you can tell
that there don't know what to say and
then you have to keep talking to like
you know keep the conversation going and
then i'm searching for stuff and then
it's like okay well this was fun it's
just like weird yeah yeah i like meeting
someone and getting their energy um and
like because i feel like you don't get
people's energy on facetime there's no
energy yeah that's why i'm gonna be hard
to get their purse or sometimes you do
sometimes their personality doesn't
shine through because it never will yeah
yeah you know what i mean that's you
know sometimes i'm like i'm not gonna
this is like
i just can't do this yeah you know it's
like yeah are you a big dating app guy i
mean i'm trying i'm just trying to put
myself out there i figure the more
conversations the more face times the
more coffee dates i don't go out on a
dinner yeah or anything unless i like
dinner first never
are you ripping are you ripping raya or
what uh uh i'm i'm my mom i'm on some of
the dating sites
but you know what i saw that girl just
leave out of the theater yeah you wish
i wish it was that easy um no but i uh i
went out on a coffee date with someone
and uh you know i i she didn't look at
your pictures she just did it i just did
it's so easy to edit yourself now it's
so easy and i get anxiety i look hot as
[ __ ] on social media now because it's so
easy to just edit yourself i mean are
you in a dating app
i'm on raya but i just feel like it's do
you have shots of you that look like you
see you're one of those guys that every
picture you take looks like because
you're a good-looking guy yeah i don't
know i don't know i'm the one that's
gotta like just try to take good shots
because not every shot is a good shot
yeah you're you're a trip no i'm telling
you i'm getting old and it's just like
[ __ ]
and now a word from our sponsor
better help better help has been with me
been with us on this podcast for quite
some time i think they believe in the
podcast and it's obviously that we
believe in them
we both use betterhelp uh
you you can
i could speak to you right now
especially yeah i can vouch for it yeah
you can i've seen your whole disposition
change from the time you started therapy
oh really until now absolutely in fact
when you talk about therapy you smile
you're kind of like it's just it's an
outlet for you isn't it that's good to
know yeah i just feel a change there's a
good change um you know this is a good
question how well would you take care of
your car if you had to keep the same one
your entire life well that's how our
brains work so why don't we treat them
that way
how we take care of our minds affects
how we experience life so it is
important to invest time and care into
keeping them healthy and there are
plenty of ways to support a healthy
brain learning a new language taking
power naps i love that but there's also
better help online therapy ryan you were
stressed up bottled up all these things
were
you know kind of just like dragging you
down a little bit and then you said i'm
gonna try this and i was surprised i was
like you know being that they were a
sponsor i didn't assume you'd be like
yeah i'm going to jump on this one
and you did
and and uh what can you say well it
helped for sure uh
i mean you're still in it i'm still in
it yeah i found a good therapist uh
and she's been really helpful and it's
been really really good i love that i
yes and if if you can tell that my
disposition has changed then i think
that's a good sign yeah you just seem
like you're happier to be here
you're happier to you're just more
present i mean not that you weren't
present but uh i take it man i dig it i
dig it i'm glad i'm glad it's helping
better help is online therapy that
offers video phone and even chat only
therapy sessions so you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to i like to see people but you don't
have to it's much more affordable than
in-person therapy i could vouch for that
it is way way more affordable than that
and you can be matched with a therapist
in under 48 hours our listeners here at
inside of you get 10 off their first
month at betterhelp.com
inside that's better h e l p dot com
slash inside if something's bothering
you if you've got a lot on your mind if
you're bottling it all up i strongly
suggest you give better help online
therapy a chance they really help
inside of you is brought to you by
shopify what i would not do what i
wouldn't do
without shopify shopify
my shopify account for my podcast has
truly
truly grown and it's something that
scared me having some website to handle
all the merch and all the stuff and then
i realized shopify
is so easy to use
uh it's surprisingly easy guys if i can
do this i don't read directions i i i
i don't do things well you you know this
if you listen to the podcast
having shopify
is
is like i don't know what i would do
without them that's honest to god i have
a shopify account you get you guys go
there it's the inside of you online
store um and it's grown exponentially
shopify gives entrepreneurs the
resources once reserved for big
businesses so upstarts startups and
established businesses alike can sell
everywhere synchronize online and
in-person sales and effortlessly stay
informed scaling your business is a
journey of endless possibility believe
me i think i started selling a t-shirt
when this thing started
now i'm selling lunch boxes and
scripts and
signed mugs and tumblers and hats and
the list goes on uh this is uh and you
what's great is you could see how well
you're doing what's your top item that's
selling how much you're making this
month what items aren't selling well how
many you have left of this item it's so
easy it's so right there in front of you
that anyone can do this so if you're if
you're looking to
to sell stuff i don't know how you don't
try shopify i don't know that there is
anybody else but shopify is there ryan
not that i know of so hey shopify i
think you're the only way to go like
mine shopify powers millions of
businesses from first sale to full scale
reach customers online and across social
networks with an ever-growing suite of
channel integrations and apps including
facebook instagram tick tock pinterest
and more gain insights as you grow with
detailed reporting of conversion rates
profit margins and beyond more than a
store shopify grows with you this is
possibility powered by shopify go to
shopify.com
inside all lowercase at shopify.com
inside all lowercase for a free 14-day
trial and get full access to shopify's
entire suite of features grow your
business with shopify today go to
shopify.com inside right now shopify.com
inside hey what you grew up in
providence yeah and were you were your
mom and dad together growing up yeah
they're still together they're still
together that's so funny my mom's out
here now she flew in last night and my
dad flies in friday so we're all how old
your mom my mom is 55.
yeah
your mom's five years older than me how
old's your dad uh my dad's 52 or 51. wow
yeah that's like my mom my mom's 75 my
dad's 70. nice so mom went after a
younger guy nice now did so did you have
a pretty good upbringing
yeah i mean
so
we weirdly like i grew up when i was
real young my dad had like a hundred
million dollars he was huge
wait wait wait wait wait when you were
young your dad had 100 million i was
like three my dad was worth like a
hundred million dollars is this before
the big crash yeah yeah
so he he i think he's still like one of
the top five
um
biggest largest ipo openings on wall
street ever um he was like in the
dot-com boom like it was a company
called log on america [ __ ] by the time i
was
six he was worth absolutely nothing
nothing when you say nothing not a dime
how do you lose everything
i i'm not 100 sure like because it's
still i i've never really had you know
that in-depth conversation about it from
what my understanding is the company's
stock was going down he was
28 30 or something like that so he's
that you know the company stock was
going down and i think he was using his
own money to buy more stock in the
company to keep it up which is legal but
it's not smart because you're buying
your own business that's tight right
right so yeah so i never we had like a
uh you know we had things like we lived
in this big house but by the time i was
six the lights were getting shut off
there was no like the cars were getting
repossessed like we were dead broke we
couldn't even eat dinner
so
how old are you i was
so six to 12 we were pretty destitute
really yeah and then when i was 14 to 18
in high school he had money again he's
like an entrepreneur so he'll have a
business and he'll be going well he you
became a millionaire again not a
millionaire but we were comfortable
where i was like you know we had
vehicles like he was able to get me a
car like stuff like that so i'm super
grateful by the way from the way i grew
up because i experienced absolute
poverty and i experienced you know uh
you know going so you're humble you were
humbled as were your parents so so so
grateful that that's what happened
because if my dad
had a hundred million dollars when i was
in high school i i wouldn't be you'd be
a wreck i'd be a [ __ ] night were you
a nightmare in high school were you kind
of like a partier or party animal
so i you played hockey yes
yeah so so basically what happened was
when i was
12 was my 12 and 13 were my rebellious
years i got cut from this hockey team
because so i was i went to long island
to play i would drive up every week and
i played for this team called the long
island goals we were like third ranked
in the entire world are you serious yeah
and you were that good dude my so my
summer team when i was 12 was conor
mcdavid daniel sprong um you know
jacqueline you played with these guys
yeah oh
insane like samuel blair like were you
one of the good players yeah it was top
four top four defensemen on this team um
i literally i think i played with almost
one person on every nhl team right now
um what yeah so that was that was
anybody in the rangers uh for toronto
thank you for trying just got traded to
the rangers yep sorry for boring you
with hockey yeah this is pretty intense
he's obviously he's playing with elite
players so we're gonna have to get to
the question of why didn't you prove you
know you get there yeah so so uh jimmy
vesey he obviously he was my ticket plug
before brandon
was my ticket before he's one of my
closest friends in the world so he just
got traded to l.a so um yeah there was a
lot of guys that on the rangers yeah
so what was it like in high school so
you were like so when i was 12
i started selling weed and be i got
caught from this team and i was like um
why'd you get cut because i didn't live
there but then they did i didn't live on
long island so i didn't go to practices
um i was i lived in rhode island so for
some reason the the coat there was a new
coach that came in he just cut me and
he's like i don't even care i don't care
who this kid is i want to make my own
team so he just caught me like a week
before the season started how old are
you uh
12 or 13. oh my god so then that's when
i went through my rebellious years i
started hanging out with the wrong kids
you know selling drugs doing this so
this was all sort of preparation for the
role that you're playing yeah exactly
that's why i feel like i play it so well
because i've experienced
all this
um so that and then i did
my parents caught me i got caught
smoking weed i got caught doing all this
stuff
and i remember seeing the disappointing
my dad my dad took me out to lunch and i
remember him being like like he didn't
want to bring it up he was like what are
we gonna do about this
and i remember thinking oh because two
years prior i'm playing with conor
mcdavid we're going to all these
tournaments i'm you know one of the
best ranked teams in the country and
then two years later
on drugs so i'm like [ __ ] like did you
say what are you doing you lost millions
of dollars yeah the [ __ ] you lost 80 mil
what the [ __ ]
i'm trying to sell weed to keep this
family of friends i'm trying to make 80
bucks she lost 80 mil what the [ __ ] is
this
jesus but okay so you have this
conversation which you would never be
with my dad my dad would have been just
you're going to halfway house you're
getting yeah you're out of the [ __ ]
house yeah but usually my dad would beat
my ass because he's punched me in the
face hundreds of times and i've deserved
it but your dad has punched you in the
face oh yeah but like not in like a in a
like in like a you [ __ ] know you
deserve that and i'm like yeah but kind
of like some smell like a punch in the
face like i beat the [ __ ] out of my
little brother one time i don't remember
what happened and i'm just way bigger
than him and i shouldn't have done it
whatever and then my dad just came
downstairs drilled me once the face my
nose was bleeding all this stuff and i
remember him walking upstairs and i was
like yeah i [ __ ] deserve that like
really yeah so
i mean i had great parents growing up
but i just you know you just you just
fall into the wrong crowd sometimes like
it's your surroundings was your dad a
tough italian guy that was getting
fights at bars or getting not really
because he was a known businessman in
rhode island so he wouldn't really do
that but you know he's got a lot of
friends and people in providence rhode
island et cetera et cetera um so you
know
so what conversations did he he was just
like hey did you step up after that did
you change the way i 180 because i saw
how disappointed he was hold on a second
see how loud this is now yeah but
honestly it's so weird because that
noise brings me happiness because it
reminds me of being home oh really i
love the leaf blower you love the leaf
blower oh go keep it in then let's keep
it in but so you did a 180. yeah you
listened to your dad unlike a lot of
other
14 year olds or whatever if he wasn't if
he was like you don't [ __ ] this and
that i wouldn't have but the way he did
it i was like damn like he did did he do
it where you disrespected me or
like i just like i can't believe where
we were two years ago and now this is
what you're doing like this and that and
i was like [ __ ] did you cry i didn't cry
but i was like did he cry uh no
no did your mom cry it wasn't that sweet
no one cried we were
my mom my mom was pretty upset but like
i don't think she ever cried uh all
right so you do a 180 you turn your life
around yeah because you had this
conversation with your mom mm-hmm i do
dad your dad
so what happens what you just become a
good poster child for uh don't do drugs
so i went to a new school and then i
joined a new hockey team so i was 14
playing on a junior uh hockey team
most of the guys on the team are 20 21.
um really yeah 19 to 21.
19 20 21 was like and you're 14 i was
14. i remember my first day
everyone was talking about this guy
brian suey brian sui he just got out of
jail he's our fighter and i'm like what
the [ __ ] i'm 14.
this guy just got out of jail thought
you dude did just deal yeah
not like joe you're right so i get to
the rink and we have a um a preseason
game the first shift this kid goes out
and fights three people he's
insane and i'm like this league is crazy
and it was like such an eye-opening
experience i'm like holy were you like i
gotta get out of here no no no i loved
it because i was [ __ ] crazy like that
i mean i was
by the time i was 15 i was fighting
everyone in the league and i was
fighting 20 year olds so wow you are
you're fearless yeah in that sense like
i i was and by the time i got there i
was like i was the fighter
inside of you is brought to you by geico
geico asks how would you love a chance
to save some money on insurance of
course you would after all who doesn't
love a great deal right and when it
comes to great rates on insurance for
all the things in your life
geico can help like with insurance for
your car truck motorcycle boat and rv
even help with homeowners condo or
renter's coverage you could save even
more with a special discount when you
bundle your coverages plus add the easy
to use geico mobile app available
24-hour roadside assistance and more and
choosing to switch to geico becomes an
easy choice switch today and see all the
ways you could save with great rates and
discounts it's easy simply go to
geico.com to get a rate quote or contact
your local agent and get started seeing
how much you could save
but by the way there's something to be
said about
wearing all that equipment having a
helmet having all these things and you
get in a fight you're thinking i'm
padded mostly yeah you know people think
it's so gruesome in this and you punch
in the face and stuff but you are
protected in a lot of ways and they're
gonna break it up i mean
not in that league they let them fight
yeah fighting was it was it's junior so
fighting's five minute fighting you take
your helmets and gloves off and these
guys would just go at it and i was i
came from youth hockey so that was my
next year i was like oh my god but then
once i was there for like a month i was
like okay this is like second nature you
know you were playing with the big boys
and you're doing well are you scoring
i'm doing well uh i don't think i played
every game that season i think i got i
think i only got scratch from like four
games because we were playing
there was this team that i never played
against because it was all 21 year old
fighters right and the coach was like
i'm just not gonna play him because it's
just not worth it um so but i had a good
year like that was my one of my best
years of hockey and then the following
year was
another one of my best years and that's
when i got drafted in the quebec major
junior hockey league so then that's when
i was quebec [ __ ] major major because
there was a [ __ ] league yeah yeah yeah
but the major was like just so people
didn't think i was throwing out the word
[ __ ] no no no no there's a [ __ ]
hockey league not for midges yeah
midgets like yeah i'm getting myself in
a hole here but it's true it's still
called [ __ ] it's still been called
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah it's like 18 year
old right 18 but go ahead so you get
draft in this quebec major league quebec
major junior hockey league so that's
where like crosby came from like all
these guys who who played um it's it's
like the ohl it's that the wwe how old
are you uh i'm 15 at this point wow yeah
but um so then that's when i start you
know taking it really serious but
the acting kind of came in you know i
always was the funny guy in the locker
room i was the locker room guy i just
wanted to make everyone laugh that's all
i cared about i obviously loved playing
hockey but i just remember being like i
loved before and after so when i was 12
the first thing that ever got you know
put in my head when i was on that team
in long island right before i kind of
you know got went off the long island
goals yeah this one of the coaches said
to me um because i would make jokes and
the kids wouldn't understand my jokes
but the coaches would like swivel their
head and go what did he just say because
i had older brothers you know right and
i remember he said to me he's like you
should do some type of acting or
entertainment and i was like
my thought process was he didn't want me
to compete with his son so i remember
shunning the acting and the
entertainment for years because of that
one thing he said i was like oh they
want me to do this so i don't compete
with their kids
and it was just like this strange
narrative that i had in my head that i
was like i'm not going to do that
because they don't want me to be
agripper because i was good when i was
you know when i was younger
so then cut to 16 i moved to um
pennsylvania and i'm playing on a junior
team there um and i went to high school
in pennsylvania while i was playing
and that was my like kind of first
acting class i took was at that school
it was just a beginner course yeah
because i didn't know anyone and i just
hopped right in and i was like oh this
is like who's this his new kid yeah i
think he's an athlete yeah he's like you
know what is he doing here but weirdly
enough this school this one school is
called holy cross high school in
pennsylvania in scranton
there was like 20 russian kids that went
to the school that played hockey because
the youth team the u16 team there was no
law on how many
imports you could have so the entire
yeah yeah it was they were literally the
entire u16 team was russian and this
whole every you know the high school
halls were just filled with russian
hockey players and they're all good oh
insane i mean ivan proverov who's
playing for you know the flyers like all
these guys who were who were top guys
just went to this small school in
pennsylvania it was such a weird
experience
um so then that year and then the
following year was when you know i
really kind of got into acting how did
you know you were good were people
commenting on how how good you were
where you're people that was just kind
of there was no like scene work or
anything like that it was just kind of
like fun like playful you know like the
zip zop like games like that where and
people were you know always thought it
was funny but then when i really got
into it was when you know i was still
playing junior hockey all these years so
once you graduate from high school you
play four you know you can play four
years you still have two more years
eligibility before you go play ncaa
hockey right so i had two years of not
being in high school not doing anything
just playing hockey that's when i went
to you know providence performing arts
center and you know um trinity rep and
and providence improv guild like all
stuff like that and that's when people
were like you're
like did you love it immediately
immediately because that that first year
out when i was playing when i you know
wasn't in high school was the worst year
of hockey of my life and acting and and
comedy and improv became my like escape
from how terrible everything was going
because two years before that i was
drafted in quebec league i had all these
you know colleges looking at me i did a
official at brown princeton yale harvard
all these places were you training too
hard and like doing in like acting wise
or hockey hockey i was training insanely
i would wake up at 5 00 a.m i would go
to the rink there was this guy who would
um open the uh the rink for me and then
go home and sleep at 5 00 am 5 am i go
to the rink and i just skate i do
sprints i did this like sprint workout
and then i go um that was before when i
was in high school my senior year
and then i would go to uh school go to
practice afterwards lift and then i
would stay after rink after and shoot
like a thousand so you wanted to be in
nhl you wanted to get drafted you wanted
to do this but in the back of my head i
i didn't i remember being like
it's that one thing that one thing that
i think if you really want something you
got to go 100 percent that's the way i
was with acting
once once i totally knew i didn't want
to go hockey so i had that little thing
in the back my head like i want to be an
actor do you ever regret it do you ever
do you ever think for a second like god
i would have loved to play in the nhl
not a second not really second i am so
happy with the decision that i made
sometimes i have like i i have a
recurring dream every like month or so
let me guess the dream okay
that you're in a movie playing a hockey
player no no no no but i still want to
do that yeah i do want to do that but
it's um that i'm trying to be an actor
but also juggle um playing junior hockey
and i'm like how am i going to make
auditions i have practice later i have
this dream once a month it's insane
still still
wow i can't get out how often do you
play hockey still um when i'm in la i'll
play um you know thursdays with matt
faxon on on the culvert oh you gotta let
me know the next time please do please
do play with you guys um and then when
i'm in new york i play roller um on
monday night so i'll play a little
roller coaster roller uh myself but yeah
i play once a week wow yeah all right so
all this you're playing hockey acting's
in the back your mind you're like that
this is what i'm gravitating towards
this is this is what it is when was it
that you felt like
that that's it i got it i've got it like
what was the one thing i hurt my
shoulder my second year out of um of
playing junior hockey and i officially
was like i'm i'm done i'm done i'm done
but i told my dad i was going to la to
rehab my shoulder i was like oh i'm
going to rehab my shoulder in la and he
knew i was in yeah but he had no idea
like what i really was going to do i
legitimately had like colleges that were
wanting me to go there in schools like
princeton and stuff like that so my dad
that never even crosses minded you could
have gone to these schools too yeah if i
played one more year you were good
enough you would have excelled yeah 100
right um
so i go i moved to la with my older
brother and i found an agent within like
the first week i was here and i was like
i'm not going back
how did you meet an agent i set up how
does one meet an agent i set up an la
casting profile and this guy reached out
to me and i immediately started
auditioning i mean i was what was his
name his name was adam park and you just
went to his office i went to his office
i remember i did a self tape in like
this uh is like the seedy outdoor area
he like didn't have he was like a
smaller agent right
um
yeah and then he was like yeah you need
acting classes and work but i definitely
think you were um you know you could do
well
so you went and acting classes yeah i i
went hard in acting classes i went i was
taking
seven classes a week i was doing five
scene study classes two improv classes i
was performing indie uh improv shows i
went insane i was doing writing i had no
idea you worked this hard i thought you
were just like a you know what they call
them what are they calling like a
influencer no a ticket influence a
ticket uh you know you know what we
could call it you just get the golden
ticket ticket yeah he just he just was
no i grinded every second every day i
wake up at 5 a.m i go to the gym then i
go open the restaurant that i worked at
then i would go to acting class at night
then if i had you know an audition i
would read sides at night like i was
great every everyone who knew me in
acting class would you know would say
this kid is insane i had teachers
telling me that i was working too hard i
was burning myself out and i just
remember being like nope i'm just gonna
get as good as i possibly can
so you would do these scenes
and know the scenes inside out and give
it a 100 and like you know just like you
could see that other people were giving
maybe twenty percent fifty percent
seventy percent yeah but you were the
hardest working one in there by far
and you you stand by that that's the
that's
and so that's kind of what made me show
up to auditions and being like i deserve
this more than everybody else because i
put in 20 000 times of work and
everything that's your mentality even
today go ahead and auditions i deserve
this i'm going to get this role you're
not everything yep it's a competition
yeah
and you don't get nervous when you go in
and audition um i used to a little bit
but now i love it i love auditioning
because you are you always prepared yes
always always always always know your
lines off book no matter what i one time
i wasn't off book because i i was too
obsessed with being off book and then um
one of my friends was like go into this
audition and don't remember anything and
just
just show how much it doesn't matter so
i was like okay cool like you got it no
i didn't get it was for it was the one
show that i shouldn't have done it for
it was for done that for it was for um
general hospital
which is like you have to know like 70
pages a day this guy can't be off book
for this one audition but it but it did
teach me something like it really didn't
matter the guy didn't care i was just it
just wasn't a good uh audition well yeah
but uh that's the one audition you
should be off before when you are off
book
or when let's say when you're reading
off script when you're reading an
audition are you
[Music]
not reading off the your sides very
often not once i don't look at it
because if i if i look at it i'm out of
the scene that's what that's what i
think the casting director thinks so i
never look at it one time i don't think
i've ever looked at my sides once i feel
like if i had a uh teleprompter or an
ear plug yeah i guess now an ear things
up then i could then i would excel yeah
i think i'm just too tired to audition
anymore yeah
all right i mean you get to that point
where you're like okay i'm not i'm not
look i'm not going to learn 10 pages of
dialogue
so they consider me when's the last
audition you went on do you still
audition i actually did i auditioned for
this movie with jessica chastain nice
lovely i was in the running for this and
um so i auditioned for that and that was
like a month ago or so nice nice um
but i don't i don't really yeah i mean
but look i appreciate the work i mean
you're 25 you're hungry you're going out
there you're going to get it what do you
where do you see yourself do you do you
want to be the guy who's at the academy
awards you want to be considered a
serious actor
what do you what do you what is it you
want i
like i were you just having fun go ahead
i just have fun and i love being an
entertainer and
you know it's my passion this is the
funnest job in the world that i could
possibly think of like i have fun every
day i get on set i try and make everyone
laugh the crew like it's the best job in
the world yeah it's also the hardest
because everyone wants to do it
um
but when you book a job like it's
everything's so so fun yeah i see myself
a little bit more like you know mark
wahlberg asked i could see that can't
you i can totally see that like i want
to do serious stuff but like i don't
need to be the guy that's like oh you
know i work you know at the academy
awards that's not me i'm not like a
hollywood type guy like i just literally
play hockey yeah i like having fun hang
out with your friends you hang out with
your brother eventually i i i see myself
at that level um of mark wahlberg you
know of being that but not at a place
where like i'm walking phoenix or
christian bale and i'm losing 900 pounds
for a roll like it's just like that's
just not fun for me do you i follow the
fun and that's not fun for me do you
still get starstruck at all um
i'm trying to think the last time it's
weird because
i i sadly like haven't
octavia spencer you had to get a little
maybe a little bit in the beginning
right when you did ma yeah when i first
went in for that chemistry read i was so
nervous and there was like eight people
and i remember walking in the first
thing she said to me was oh damn we got
a young tom cruise and i remember being
like oh i'm good i'm i'm really yeah i
knew she liked you everything went away
um which i still look like she literally
texted me yesterday screenshot marlon
brando she goes this is literally you
you you do have a resemblance to uh
brando yeah and she i was like let's do
this movie and she's like say less let's
get it going so
um i would love to do a marlon brando
biopic that'd be so cool
i could see it i could look at him
you know yeah i bet that would make your
parents happy too yeah do they love what
you're doing do they love it it's so
funny because at first my dad uh hated
it he was like no this my mom was like
more the type of go chase your dreams
and then he was on a red carpet with 50
cents he's like all right this is pretty
cool
it's like he was he was up he was for it
immediately yeah he knew 50 cent
no he knew yeah he knows you're 50 i
mean i grew up like since i was really
young i actually posted a picture on
instagram like a couple weeks ago it was
me
six years old at a hockey tournament in
las vegas and i have a g-unit t-shirt on
six years old i listened to eminem when
i was like five six seven eight i think
that's why i was so crazy because all
this music and you know i was just in a
uh um
nwa and and uh you know method man like
all these people when i was that enemy
everything fight the power yep remember
that song all right
do you ever text with 50 cent um we
sometimes i mean he's a little bit more
he's kind of in a tiff with stars about
what's going on with his shows really
yes because he um i don't really know
the logistics of it so he doesn't come
to set like he used to he used to come
all the time but right now you know he's
got his other stuff going on so we used
to talk more
um but i mean he's so supportive he's
always so nice every time he comes to
set
um he's like make videos do whatever
like we have so much fun but yeah i wish
i wish the relationship was be like it
used to be when i was power season six
because he was happy as a clam he had
four spin-offs with them this and that
um yeah what is this it's power book
there the first there was power yeah so
i was on power originally and then power
book two and then power closure two is
just a um continuation of and then
there's power book three powerbook three
raising canaan is a prequel of 50 cent's
character because he died it's a prequel
of
him growing up and then powerbook four
force yes that's um that's uh that's my
buddy tommy flanagan yeah i love tommy's
time he was just in the podcast was he
yeah it was great i don't [ __ ] do
this with these rosie but i'm gonna do
it for you i love him so much he's so
fantastic you worked with him no but i'm
just a huge sons of anarchy fan yeah
he's great um
so yeah that's that's force so that's uh
a character that was originally in power
he escaped the feds and went to chicago
and that's his story there wow so how
many episodes of this have you done
since power and then power book i did
probably 35 at this point 35 yeah and
how many more
i mean they wanted to go for a long time
like how long did you sign on for seven
years i think but i mean they need a
sketcher they sign they can kill you off
at any time yeah but they sign you on
yeah forever yeah i mean that's a long
time but nowadays you're only doing what
eight to ten episodes a season yeah it's
ten episodes and you work like what four
months six months six months yeah six
because it's our drama in new york it's
not easy is it hard work it's hard work
are you exhausted by the end of the days
yes i'm exhausted middle day i'm like oh
[ __ ] am i gonna get because i'm also
like high comedy and this and that and
then some scenes i'll have this there's
a lot of um physical stuff you need to
do running fighting
like whatever crazy [ __ ] so
that's a lot of work but a lot like
since we're dealing drugs we'll shoot in
you know bad areas and in brooklyn and
queens night shoots all the time it's
freezing cold it's hot it's always
[ __ ] cold in new york it's hard sorry
for the f-bomb it is my dad lives there
and i'm like dad it's either too
freaking hot or freezing for seven
months a year anybody who loves new york
i like to visit now every once in a
while but i can't live there and i used
to live there and i'm from new york so
don't badmouth me i'm a big fan of the
mets knicks rangers giants but i'm
telling you new york's always effing
cold yeah always and it used to be our
schedule used to be october to april but
since kovit it's now pushed to january
to july so you still get some warm
months right but yeah it's it is hard
work sometimes i'm like oh my god like
and then i talked to people who you know
i have a friend who's on the conners and
she's like yeah we shoot on the stage
and like cbs like it's warm out it's
hard
you're a sitcom you go and you do one
you know what i mean you do a day
rehearsal and then you shoot the live
show like we're shooting from six
o'clock at night to six in the morning
night shoots in snowing weather oh god
and woody and at the same time don't you
train every day
yeah i go to the gym i have every single
day for hours
and you box yeah i box i do jiu jitsu i
do muay thai
is boxing
does that keep you in shape more than
any other sport you think um it doesn't
i think it would help your cardio but
for me when i boxed a lot it made me
look um
too small and now this season you know
my character is getting even more and
more darker so i want to look big i want
to like be able to be menacing and be
strong and be tough so i had to actually
stop doing a lot of my you know boxing
muay thai jiu-jitsu because i was doing
too much cardio and i had to i had to
lift weights more
so so that's what you're doing now yeah
so you're lifting weights yeah every day
every day two hours legs
check i don't do legs because my legs
can't fit because i played 20 years of
hockey so your legs are just already in
shape yeah but my legs i already have to
get custom pants at wardrobe like
wardrobe has to make pants for me
because i can't fit my legs in normal
pants because of hockey are you serious
yeah
it's crazy you're lucky i have the
skinniest [ __ ] legs ever and i played
hockey most of my life in other sports i
just had skinny legs about you ryan i
might i got skinny legs no but you're
like i got some berry jeans
uh people got some questions for you
this is called [ __ ] talking with gianni
paulo it's paulo right paolo but it
looks apollo here's the thing it's pale
it's been pale for two you know my
grandfather my dad
um so i've always said paolo my older
brother says paulo now for some reason
but he also goes to subway and it's like
mozzarella so i'm like uh i'm not gonna
take what you say serious ever you know
what i mean he'll call me but he's like
paolo i'm like it's
paolo yeah paolo gianni payolo did you
have a big upbringing like italian
upbringing yeah big italian family big
italian talk about that for a second
what's it what's that like was it fun oh
it's the most fun i mean my whole
family's insane like if you met my dad
you would go this guy is [ __ ] how
does he talk
he's just very violent and animated and
he's very similar to me like we're
similar people um but yeah he's my mom's
crazy my whole family's [ __ ] nuts
well what he did sorry are you not
supposed to wear it you know no you guys
no no no no no but he no you i try not
to f bomb just for because it's i hate
always i just yeah i don't give a i
don't give an s yeah
yeah yeah i don't really care about it i
don't haven't care you can go s a d for
all i at
um
no but like
if you asked him like is he is he very
like uh you know does he like talking
about like the past your dad remember
putting him in the face he will he
remembers things like that yeah he'll
talk oh yeah he brings it up because
yeah you're a pain in the ass here's one
story my older brother was my older
brother had this mustang when he was 17.
he would you know whip around the
streets for this and that one time my
dad saw him on the road going like
so we had you know what a billet kit is
no so when i was 14 we had a kid from um
i had a kid from russia i had a kid from
connecticut and a kid from massachusetts
come and stay at my house in rhode
island and live with our family
to play in the junior hockey team
i was on the junior b team so i was 14
and he was on the junior a team which
was like jimmy veezy like all these kids
who are nhl players now charlie coyle
wow so
these kids played on uh two were on my
team and one were one was on the junior
18. so it's the kids first day staying
with us he gets in the car my older
brother and my older brother's whipping
through the streets whatever um it's
night time so uh my brother didn't
really see my dad so my dad starts
following him through the streets and
he's flashing his lights flashing his
lights my older brother my little
brother who the hell is this so he stops
at the stop at the stop sign he puts a
car in park and he gets out and he turns
around like what the [ __ ] and it's my
dad and he just punches him square in
the face don't ever drive like that uh
on these streets this and that punch him
squaring his face he's bleeding he gets
back in the car and i'm really close
with the kid who used to live with us so
i remember him the kid's like he's
horrified he's like i have to live with
his family for the next eight months oh
my god it was like silence in the car
and my older brother is like just
bleeding all over the place i love how
you like italians i have a friend tommy
caprio and he always talks about oh yeah
we used to get beatens all the time yeah
you know my dad would beat me and beat
my little brother joey it's like we
deserved it we got beat 100 and people
are like you know nowadays you don't
touch your kids you don't hate your kids
i disagree with that because yeah you do
yeah i disagree that i i mean i just but
do you think you you the father should
punch his son square in the face i don't
i i would say every situation is
different right but for us 100 we were
little [ __ ] and you could take a
punch easily was he a big guy yeah my
dad's
my dad's pretty ripped like he's pretty
big dude and he'd go full punch full
punch
did anyone ever stand up and punch him
back
no oh no no no no no even to this day
you wouldn't do that that'd be it nope
never he'd kill you yeah he'd kill us
never
but you think now he has a carry so he's
always got a gun on him like i'm good he
carries a gun yeah because he does
security now he does like security um
uh he has this company called skypath
security where they go and they do
threat assessments in like schools and
stuff like that
so he always has a gun and i'm like i'm
good
you think that like in a childhood like
this i mean you you seem pretty freaking
normal with all the stuff you did but i
think that's why i am normal it's like
the kids who have like hollywood
childhoods like they're [ __ ] insane
yeah they're like they grow their hair
out so they look like brad pitt or
something and and they just give them a
skateboard and they all act like
[ __ ] so they go to prison they're
our moms i don't even care about
listening and they're smoking pot at
like nine think about the economic state
of the world like just stuff yeah that's
that wasn't me
so so you really like appreciate your
parents oh yeah
and your mom she was loving i love you
son your dad too i love you give me a
hug give me a kiss did he used to give
you a kiss yeah
my my dad wasn't really affectionate but
my mom was very affectionate for some
reason i was never affectionate until i
got an acting class and like had to like
submit to being like vulnerable and open
so my mom used to call me her prickly
pear when i was in um
i remember i was young i was like 11 10
11. because she would like give me
affection i hated it i hate it i don't
know what it was really and then now i'm
like a little more open to it but i'm
still like what about with women like
when you date a girl are you are you
affectionate i don't really i don't know
like pda is like the worst thing in the
world to me okay you will not get past i
will never ever ever like hug her kids
hold a hand uh it's it's like and they
hate it because you won't yeah i just do
not like it i want everybody to know i'm
your girl yeah
yeah and i struggle i'm not a
relationship guy at all i struggle well
you're 25 you don't really need to think
about that right yeah in fact i would i
don't think you need to worry about it
for 10 years yeah you just don't agree
like focus on your life focus on your
career do you get any anxiety ever do
you ever get anxiety or any depression
or you've never really experienced you
seem like such a happy guy that nothing
really affects you obviously i do like i
go through it but i'm just so motivated
and i have so much fun i'm grateful for
my life so i and every i mean all the
work i put in everything i just know
it's gonna work out so i don't really
stress like that like sometimes stuff
creeps in where you're like okay like
when the show's over like doesn't it
like stuff like that sure but i've
that's gone away now because i'm like i
i know what my path is and i'm not
worried you know and you're starting a
business now yeah i read this with your
with your buddy from uh
power yeah my co-star michael rainey jr
we just started a production company
with uh keenan thompson keenan thompson
yeah
how did you how did that happen i have a
buddy who's from rhode island who's his
business partner as well and um we just
linked up one time and we just honestly
like keenan really messed with my vibe
and you know we had a conversation he's
like yeah they're like this is like this
kid i want to be in business with so i
love him i think he's one of the
funniest coolest guys i go to like every
snl now and i kick it with him all the
time like he's the coolest are you
serious could you get him on the podcast
yeah i'll talk to kanye did he do it
yeah you do it because he has a podcast
too and with the same network that we're
we're doing ours with and he um yeah he
would love to do it dude i would love
keenan i think keenan's brilliant yeah
fans he's amazing he's an a legend like
so he's done a thousand skits or
something yeah he i think he's the
longest running cast member by like six
or seven years did he ever say i'll get
you on the show i'm gonna get you on the
show i mean i want me and michael the
host one day but it's weird because the
mainstream uh networks don't pick up
power stuff even though we're like the
third most stream show in the world
um
it's like the stuff that we get picked
up is like uh you know hip hop stuff
double xl magazine like which is dope
like that's everything i love growing up
but i'm like i wish these mainstream
like
networks would you know mess with us you
know what though
you end up doing a different show yeah
and then you appeal to those people you
get everyone and then the other people
yeah you're appealing to everybody
that's kind of the goal yeah get on
something a little more commercial but
in it with a different audience i agree
i'm already i agree
that's how you do it all right this is
called [ __ ] talking with gianni paolo as
he calls himself not his brother that's
the way to do it uh these are my patrons
my lovable patrons who support the
podcast to give back to keep the podcast
afloat i love you guys uh go to
patreon.com inside of you uh so little
lisa says who's on your bucket list to
meet
conor mcgregor
conor mcgregor yeah i don't like those
commercials he does
the irish risky ones
he's nervous yeah he is there he
probably is yeah it's funny because
someone like that goes into a ring with
someone and has no nerves at all and
then they get on camera and they're like
isn't that something
someone could kill you what would you
say to him if you met him
i don't know like i i don't really have
any starstruck people with like music or
acting much anymore um
but i think him like that i just i've
looked up he's just a badass he's just a
badass he's cool he's made so much money
doing what he loves too and i don't know
he doesn't give a [ __ ] he's fearless he
doesn't give a [ __ ] he'll still show up
places and he's still like fights people
i don't know i just in pubs yeah like he
he doesn't let any type of hollywood
stuff face i don't know i just think
he's cool
fearless yeah uh mary b
would you rather have a leading role in
a romantic comedy or a horror film
i did a horror film so i want to do a
romantic comedy
at this stage of my life do you want to
be the leading guy yeah the leading guy
in a romantic comedy yeah i want to be
that matthew mcconaughey but what if you
have to be affectionate and [ __ ] oh i'm
fine i could do it on screen all the
time on screen but just not in real life
yeah yeah yeah i can get it out and
scream were your parents affectionate
yeah uh to each other yeah they would
kiss in front of you yeah every day get
over here yeah every day before work
does not so i mean great this is crazy
but sometimes my dad like i would get
home at like 3 a.m you know me my
friends are out cause my place was like
the hub in high school where everyone
hung out right and you know we'd have
girls over this and that my parents let
us do whatever we wanted because they
trusted me because in high school i
didn't smoke or drink one time from 14
18. not once
um
so my parents trusted me so everyone
would just come over
the girls would leave whatever and we'd
all be in the kitchen heating up food
from the night before my mom would
always cook a lot and then my dad would
come in the kitchen like 3 4 a.m and go
look at me just just bang your mom i'm
like what the hell
what he goes you think the only one
getting some of this house he goes just
bang your mom i'm like okay bro i didn't
need to hear that i just banged your mom
oh that's the city would say to me
i mean that's like the relationship that
we have when you were how old i was
probably
16 17. 16. so this is 10 years ago so he
was probably 40s yeah early 40s yeah i
just banged your mom
like do you say dad i don't want to hear
this that's i'd be like dude and my
friends are eating it up also my dad's
like he's like me he's milking it he's
putting on a little show
my friend my friends what's his name
your dad dave your mom's always like
dave literally yeah dave
ugh and they've been together how long
um
they got 30 years 1992 they got married
i think 82 it's that's 02 12 92 30 years
yeah 30 years dana s are you a fan of
your own show power and the book of
ghost if so how crazy were the major
deaths in the show they knocked me out i
i didn't watch
any power before i was on it and then i
finished um shooting the original power
and then i watched it on like four days
and i was like i'm on the show this is
everything i've ever wanted to do it's
insane it's like
guns drugs you know murder this and that
like everything i wanted to do the way i
look i'm like i'm gonna be a vampire
forever
you know what i mean
so i'm like oh no this is great and yeah
ghost i mean
it's
it's it's everything i've ever wanted to
do wow i love that it's so great to be
on a show that you really love love
every script comes in on my comments
there's nothing worse there's nothing
worse than being on a show that you're
like have you experienced that yeah i've
been on shows that i just feel like
people don't care as much around you
there's not much enthusiasm
um
you know it just feels like
it's not as exciting but then i've been
on things that are really exciting yeah
i've done a couple of things the scripts
come out and and everyone's like oh my
god like i read it the second i get it
and everyone's like who dies who dies
who dies like that's the way it is so
everyone's always enthusiastic i've
never been
on a show where you know i probably get
there but like where i'm just like i
don't really care
i love it like i love being on on power
i love it raj are there specific movies
or tv shows that inspired you to pursue
an acting career
what what i was watching when i did move
out to la i uh was sons of anarchy i was
like i'm think i thought it was jax
teller i almost got a motorcycle when i
got here like i i don't like motorcycles
yeah i don't either they're so dangerous
i know i sound like a grandpa but it's
like it's not you i'm worried about it's
like the people around you when you're
riding motorcycles yeah you know i don't
want to have to worry about the things
that i can't control exactly and it
always freaks me out yeah you always
hear about these accidents i know it's
scary always right
my dad just got a motorcycle like a
month ago are you serious
he's 55 and he just got it he got a
harley
yeah what do you say to him dad be
careful i'm just like like why like
there's no why do you need a motorcycle
he's crazy
he sounds a little crazy 25 stuck in a
55 year old guy's body my god he must
love what you're doing though now oh
yeah he just loves it we went to the
ranger game they put me up on i saw that
yeah they put me up on the thing and he
was like trying to like get in i'm like
like he had his sky-path security hoodie
on and he's like trying to get it in on
the thing
yeah he's crazy you still you go to as
many ranger games as you want oh yeah
they give they give us tickets why is
that big so power is like a staple new
york show like when i'm in america when
you're in new york people recognize
insane i can't even walk to the gym in
the gym in the morning like i
work out you know kind of ten blocks
where i am it's insane i can't walk down
are you serious
because i'm like this is crazy when i
get in l.a no one gives a [ __ ] i mean
it's still a huge fan base but it's also
la so no one cares anyways but when i'm
in new york like i can't go anywhere
your son on autographs can also take
pictures constantly it's literally it's
just such a new york show so everyone in
new york watches it jesus everywhere we
go we get comped i don't think i've ever
paid for anything in new york city it's
crazy
wow dude
that's amazing yeah leanne what's your
favorite type of role to play and why or
maybe you haven't even played that role
yet yeah what i'm doing right now i like
being like a badass like i like
it's just cool i mean eventually get to
a place where that'll change and i want
to do something else because everyone
always gets there as an actor where the
grass is always greener
but right now it's what i'm doing now
which andy t
when did you know that you wanted to
pursue an acting career we talked about
that yeah but you were playing you were
playing hockey yeah
and you you thought i gave you this the
smaller the smaller version but yeah
when i was around like 10 or 11.
jesus man what about you when how old
were you when you
i think i did my you know i started
liking it in high school yeah i took a
drama class
did you do it for girls because that's
what a lot of people no i just i just
didn't fit in anywhere else and then i
remember i was in drama class and i was
drama it was drama
it was just drama class so freshman year
you took drama sophomore you took drama
third year you took drama finally my
teacher said listen
i'm not going to allow you to take drama
your senior year unless you audition for
a play yeah oh i see something and i
said oh
i was too nervous yeah so finally i go
okay
and i auditioned for vince fontaine in
the in greece did you get it and i got
it nice and that's what that's what
did it for me
but to this day i still never i'm always
been nervous always and i think you know
part of that helps me yeah part of that
hurts me yeah but it's like you get that
nervous energy you get that like but
when i'm in the zone yeah when i really
know something i really love something i
really feel like
that there's no feeling like that yeah
see i struggled my first year
auditioning because everything i went in
for
was confident jock good looking guy this
and that and
i always struggled because i wasn't
confident in auditioning i was confident
in life but when i would go in the
audition so i never embodied the
confidence because that's what i had to
play so i'm like what the [ __ ] they're
always giving me confidence confidence
give me something i'm not confident i'll
kill this right now but then i got
better at auditioning i was like okay
cool like i can do this now how how many
followers do you have now i don't even
know like six hundred thousand or so yes
and which what's what's your uh
instagram
it's at gianni v paolo
i'm telling you i looked on there one
day and it was like you had 30 000
followers and it seems like the next day
you had 600 and something else yeah it
was after season two of ghost when i
just started you know really being were
you just going crazy like oh my god look
at all these people following me yeah i
mean we also had like this little back
and forth where with um you know that
guy that went crazy viral it's the 50s
other show called black mafia family bmf
it's on stars and all those guys were um
[ __ ] on our show so we started
[ __ ] on their show on social media
so then the shade room picked it up like
what do you mean [ __ ] on your show
like they would just be like oh uh we
have the number one rated show which
isn't true we have the number one rated
show on stars um
but so they started like tagging us and
all this stuff and then everything just
went crazy viral like the shade room
picked it up entertainment tonight
picked it up like all this stuff picked
it up and i remember like i got i think
i got like a hundred thousand followers
that day or something
yeah do you have anybody offer you like
uh to post things for money yeah yeah
all the time but i'm pretty like picky
about that stuff i don't want to align
myself with brands that i don't like
what's the most money been offered to
post
i mean so we do booking we do club
bookings like that's what i'll do so me
and my co-star will go to a club and
they'll pay us like you know 20 grand
and we'll just literally go to like a
club and party for an hour
20 grand for you to just hang out at a
club ryan are you hearing this
nobody asked me to come to a club for 20
years it's just our show like that's our
like they'll they'll come out and see us
because people are so it's like hip-hop
culture this and that like and you get
mobbed in there it's insane i've never
we have armed security guards with us at
all times like it's crazy
so that's like what what i'll do like
for extra money like i won't the stuff
posting on instagram i'm like i just i
could care what about being on a show
like stars
do they pay you well yeah they do yeah
was it good pay right away or did you
have to negotiate for that um because
they probably tried to take advantage of
you they did but i knew um
i knew how i was already written in the
storyline so i was like i'm going to
step up that was the mistake they made
yeah i'm going to stand firm
jesus yeah
who else do you know for the podcast
you know me if you ever text me like i
will i will you know everybody because
you're a likable good guy so that's how
i got hooked up with you you've hooked
me with theo yeah of course i've i
forgot who who we've had on inside you
but that's how i got hooked up with theo
because i was in mississippi filming ma
and um
one of the pas i was in my dressing room
listening to this past weekend and at
this point it was six months before you
even came on right so
no one was listening to i think he had
like 20 or 30 000 listeners he had like
40 000 followers on instagram yeah so it
was very very very small show so the pa
who came to my dressing room was like we
just listened to theo van i was like
yeah so it was like a niche thing and
he's like i know him and i was like oh
really like i'm a big fan of him i'd say
i'm seeing him at the comedy store a
bunch of times i was like hook me up
with him um when i get back to l.a he's
like no problem so i went back to la i
shot this movie i had enough money in my
pocket where i didn't need to work a
restaurant job anymore
and he um that's when i started working
with theo and booking and doing this and
that so i was acting and filming stuff
while i was working with theo did you
like working with theo he's one of my
best friends in the entire world i love
him he's the funniest person he really
is hysterical he's got such a unique
there's very few comedians that are so
unique they're in their own little
place that
he just he just it's off the cuff it's
just like innately part of him the
things he says the things he does he
just shares them with the world the
things that he thinks about yeah but he
is pretty insane he um
that was like even in real life when you
talk to him because you meet a lot of
comedians that are really funny on stage
and they're just like like sebastian's a
good example i've had tons of
conversations with sebastian maniscalco
he's just not that guy to try and you
know riff in in person he's very normal
but on stage he's a murderer right
theo's a murderer on stage he's funnier
off stage when he can say stuff that he
can't say on stage like oh my god like
stuff that you would not believe like
this guy's insane he's so funny he's
insane have you seen him just uh destroy
it in front of thousands of people yeah
i went on tour with him a couple months
ago before i started filming and
yeah i was on the god mic i was like
theova like we just have really any time
theos has a show anywhere near him i'll
fly out and go see him like we just have
such a good relationship that's great i
really i have a lot of love for him i'm
gonna go see him on saturday he's said
that netflix is a joke festival oh
really yeah so what's next you're just
doing the show yeah so i got
maybe
three more months in new york doing the
show um i am
doing like a lot of my own producing for
television shows and um and films that
i'm getting going and i just started a
power after show podcast with my um
co-star michael rainey jr which our
first episode came out yesterday and
we're second on the charts right now for
podcasts so what yeah it's pretty crazy
we're second for tv and film and i think
top 100 in the world wait what's it
called it's called the crew hazard with
michael rainey jr and gianni palo and we
just take all the shows because it's
such a big universe so we're going to
take all the actors from all the shows
have them come in we'll talk about
episodes this and that there's so many
shows so it's like why not have a little
hub for it that's the way to do it yeah
we're doing it with a lot of shows now
yep kind of re-watch shows yeah
yeah that's what we're doing so it
killed it yesterday so i'm i'm super
excited like i'm just i just love doing
this i love it you got such a great
you know your personality your energy
it's there's no wonder why you have so
much success and you deserve it man
thank you i love seeing good people do
good things yeah and do things that make
them happy yeah so hey dude thanks for
allowing me to be inside of you today of
course this has been a real are you
going to get inside of me after you got
inside of me after this well whatever
you want whatever you want buddy
we'll see what happens we'll see what
happens dude thanks so much thanks mike
i appreciate it all right dude it's
awesome
i'm jealous that he's so good-looking
and he's talented and he's so happy yeah
i want to be that happy don't we all
want to be that happy and sometimes we
hate happy people but that's wrong no
you should look at that and go good for
them yeah and of course i don't hate
gianni i i love that he's happy and i
and i root for people and i root for a
guy like him because he's got a great
heart and um
i really mean that and i i want
everybody to be happy but also i think
it's just that you're envious that we
god i want to feel that whatever you're
feeling i want to hang out with you i
want to
you know i want to dress like you
i'm going to drive in your fancy car
i just love the guy hey man gianni
you're a good dude man i thank you for
uh being on the show on the podcast uh
check out all this stuff um
i think you'll uh you'll enjoy it
what else we got here we got talkville
the big podcast tomorrow
talkville it's exciting the smallville
rewatch podcast tomorrow guys
make sure you tune in subscribe become a
patreon if you want it's going to be a
ride it's a lot of work on this end but
we're having fun ryan you having a good
time i'm having a good time yeah it's uh
i'm
watching it for the first time i know
it's cool to see your perspective on
things it really is cool
i um
it's actually cool to see my perspective
on things like now
after not seeing the show for
so many years and i hadn't seen a lot of
episodes so i when i'm watching these
episodes i have no clue what's gonna
happen i'm just like you except i'm in
them
and i'm at times going oh my gosh why
did you make that choice how's clark
gonna get out of this one
i wonder if he will i wonder the show
will be over
if he doesn't get out of it
um anyway talk phil tomorrow so tell me
what you think and there's also a
hotline you can call
and leave messages make sure they're
short with your questions and we'll try
to get you on the air but we can only
afford to put on a couple on without
unless they're just fantastic questions
unless you just ask something that no
one's ever asked before
like michael what's the size of your
suit that lex wore that'd be a boring
question what was the size of your suit
um i don't know probably a 40 long
42 long
that is boring you're right it's very
boring see how long we got we won't be
talking about that on smallville
talkville um hey guys if you want to
become a patreon support inside of you
podcast please do and i will message you
right after you do that's patreon.com
inside of you we've got great great
fantastic merch just check out the merch
on the inside of you online store
smallville stuff inside of you stuff
everything you can dream for we're
running out of i think lunch boxes i
think we only have two lunchboxes left
signed by me and tom
willing some scripts lexma scripts that
i sign uh
funko pops which are going out like
what
goes out like they're selling like
hotcakes that's what they're doing the
kids they're selling my cupcakes
good lord almighty ryan is taking off
he'll be gone for a couple of weeks but
uh he'll be back and uh
uh there might just be an episode
without ryan
you won't know or will you you might
know in the future next week you'll know
all right if ryan's not on that episode
chances are
he wasn't here
he wasn't here uh that's it that's all i
have today
um
i wish you all a wonderful week thanks
for supporting the podcast um
before we do that i think i need to read
some
names don't i oh you should yeah these
are the names these are the top tier
patrons go to patreon.com inside of you
get their names shouted out every
episode nancy d leah s sarah v little
lisa yukiko jill he brian h nico p
robert
p jason w kristen k
raj c joshua d cj p jennifer and stacey
l jamal
f janelle
b kimberly e mike e eldon supremo 99
ra mira santiago m chad d w correct
leanne p janine r maya p matty s belinda
n chris
h dave h sheila g brad d rey h tabitha t
tom and liliana a talia
t
c
m [ __ ] betsy
d
chad
uh d just remember chad l andra mira no
uh rochelle chad rochelle and rochelle
chad ellen rochelle marion
meg
c
k k trav
l dan n big stevie w and angel
m correct rhiannon c corey
f k
cory k cory k let's think of something
you remember that corey k
corey can do it any way she wants
or he put it with a k
super
sam dev nixon michelle k a hey
just remember michelle a not k
jeremy
i don't know r c
andy
f t
cody
i see we're we're in the room i don't
know cody r cody r cody
codier cody r gavin nader david
c john
heater
i don't know what that b john b brandy
l d
brandy d
yeah for camille
s
correct the c joey
fatone m correct willie
nelson
how about willie felson willie felson
will that help you yeah david
and goliath h david h david h
just remember david hyde pierce h david
h all right
do you hear that
i can't fart
design
i don't know otg general
eugene
levy and leah chris
remember chris pratt or chris chris p
chris p nikki remember glazer nikki g g
corey
just corey
katie b
remember katy berry instead of katy
perry
will that help you sure nicole
patricia
heather
l remember heather lockier lyric
is it locklear locklear yeah
jake b remember jake busey
that's easy james b maybe james bunn
instead of james
yeah gun all right bobbitt sure megan t
uh-huh megan drinks tea megan t
uh mel
s orlando c orlando cloom
john b
yuch
caroline r robbie just robbie
paul
c christine s sarah s eric h spring
jennifer r shane r m r mark m jeremy v
andrew m robert g zatoichi 77 andreas n
alexandra and chris are those are the
top tiers ryan you did a spectacular job
there are a lot more
are there more yeah
there's a lot of names that i do not
recognize yeah well there are some good
names some good newbies thank you for
joining patreon i appreciate it if you
want to join patreon go to patreon.com
inside of you thank you for listening to
the podcast thank you for allowing me to
be inside of all of you today it means a
ton i went to australia and i couldn't
believe the amount of love that was
given to this podcast and how it helps
so many people
and it gives me purpose so you give me
purpose thanks for
sticking with me and putting up with me
and all my little idiosyncrasies and
and faults and everything else
um thank you thank you from the
hollywood hills in california i am
michael rosenbaum i'm ryan
and uh we love you be good yourself
thank you for letting me inside of each
and every one of you and until next week
um
much love to you be good to yourself
[Music]